Hello everybody and welcome to another
episode of my road to one bill series.
Today we are going to be training our
magic. So we're going to focus in pretty
hard in on that. Um, although we did
just get a strength level so we're 65.
Um, but yeah, we are going to try to get
80 magic in the next couple episodes.
Um, today we're going to start the
initial progress for that though. Okay,
so what we're going to start off by
doing is just telling to Camelot over
and over again. Um, we need to get our
magic to 55 before we can actually start
alking.
Um, and then we're going to try
tele-alking I think.
As well as possibly alking while doing
some agility.
Um, but we're going to start with the
Camelot teleports. It's really easy. I
mean it's like the easiest thing in the
game. You just click the same spot over
and over again. And you get about 80k
experience an hour. So not bad. Okay, so
now we are going to try alking stuff.
And we noticed that the air battle
staffs actually were a 100% break even.
And the nature rune right now is like
254 coins. I think it's what I ended up
buying them for. Um, roughly. So it's
pretty much 100% break even on the
alking. The only problem with this item
is it's kind of expensive. Like I can
only get 500 with my cash stack pretty
well.
Um, so yeah. It but it is break even. So
it does help quite a bit. So I'm going
to try to buy as many of these as I can.
And then I'm going to actually I think
I'm going to do some agility while
alking. Ooh, look at me being all
efficient now. Okay, so we've managed to
buy 260 of the air battle staffs so far.
Um, and yeah, I think we're just going
to alk them while we're doing some
agility cuz we're getting pretty close
to another piece. Uh, we're going to go
for the graceful bottoms now.
Um, cuz they give the greatest weight
reduction. And uh, it's just more
efficient to go for that one first I
think. Um, but yeah, I've never really
done this before. I'm not really an
efficient Runescape player but uh, we'll
give this a try. Trying to alk while
we're doing the Canifis rooftop course.
Okay, I think I'm kind of getting the
hang of this. Um,
we'll ignore that cuz I I had to start
the recorder. But um,
most roofs you can get one alk in. I'm
probably going a little a slower agility
experience.
Um, but I'm getting about 25 to 30k
magic experience, which is pretty
decent. And uh the Let's be real here.
The agility experience here is
anyway, so it's not like a big loss. I'm
only getting like 15k agility experience
here.
Um, but that being said, we are about to
hit an agility level. So, we're about to
get to 53, uh which is nice, and we just
need a couple more marks of grace.
Okay, that is all the battle staves
done.
Um
Honestly, only took me about 45 minutes
or something to go through all these
battle staves, so I kind of need more.
Um but that being said, we have gotten
enough marks of grace.
So, we can go buy the graceful bottoms,
which will be pretty exciting.
Um cuz that only leaves two pieces left.
Two pieces and I'll finally have the
actual full graceful set for the first
time ever. Okay, here we're at the shop,
and let's buy these graceful legs. 60
marks of grace. Let's go.
And that's great. That gives us another
Let's see. We're at minus seven.
And now we're at minus 14. Look at those
pants. They look pretty damn sweet.
Okay, so now we're going to try some
tele alching, and um we're buying magic
longbows because we can instantly buy
them. We're going to lose like 100 GP on
each alc, but um
I'll need more than like 500 cuz I'm
going to be going through them very
quickly.
So, we're just going to go with the
magic longbows or whatever I ended up
buying.
So, we're going to try doing 500 of
these. So, what you need is a fire staff
or an air staff equipped, and then
you're going to need 500 law runes, 500
nature runes,
and 500 of the item you're going to alc,
um
or more than 500. However you much
you're doing, but you just need an even
ratio.
And as far as I'm aware, it's pretty
easy. It's You just click on both the
spells. They happen to be very close
together, which is nice.
Um and it gets you about 120k experience
an hour. It's a bit click intensive, but
honestly, once you get used to it, it's
not too bad. You can just watch a movie,
and you just kind of got that motion
going. Really not too bad. Uh as you can
see in the background here I'm doing it.
You alk
Uh
didn't do it right there. You alk and
then you tele right away and then you
wait until you're just with the spawn
and then you alk and then you teleport
again.
Um
And yeah, I'm getting 120k experience.
It's uh cost me about 500k an hour to do
this though. So it's kind of expensive,
but it is
quite a bit quicker than a lot of other
magic methods. Uh we're actually about
to just hit a level here.
Um so we're going to do these 500. Uh
what did we get? 57 magic. Yeah. Okay,
and we just hit another magic level. We
just hit 59 magic. Uh we only have 100
casts left. So we're going to kind of go
buy I think a couple more after this and
try to get 66 magic.
Okay, so we calculated we need about
2,000
casts to get 66 magic. And what we're
looking there for is to be able to make
air orbs.
Um which gets you about I think 30 or
40k magic experience an hour, but you
also get about 400k in profit.
Um so it'd be nice to have a profitable
way of training magic on top of a quick
way that costs a lot of money.
Um so yeah, we're going to buy 2,000 of
each rune and then I think we're just
going to go cast all these spells and
get right to 66.
Okay, we just hit level 60 magic I
think. Yeah. Perfect. And um yeah, we'll
come back probably when we actually hit
66 magic. Okay, I lied again. So we're
back and we've used about 1,000 of the
casts so far. Um which I think has
gotten us to 63 magic. I'm not going to
sit here and say that this is the most
entertaining way to level up your magic,
but it is definitely much quicker than
most.
Um
And if you do manage to buy the nature
runes or the alk bolts at a decent
price, you won't actually be losing too
much money. Um but it looks like I'm
using about 500k an hour. So yeah, 63
magic and we'll keep on alking the rest
of these. Okay, we are almost done. I've
definitely got the hang of this now.
Um
you get used to it pretty quickly and
honestly, the movement isn't too much
harder than just casting the teleport.
I just click on the alk, click on the
teleport, wait 2 or 3 seconds, and
repeat. It's not much more challenging
or click intensive than just casting the
Camelot teleport, and it's almost double
the experience. So, I recommend it if
you have the cash to actually level up
your magic pretty quickly. And there we
go, 66 magic will let us cast our big
air orbs, which is kind of exciting.
Okay, so we just finished off a farm
run, so we're going to sell off the
herbs. Uh I know the seeds are rising up
a little bit, but still
definitely still worth it. I'm getting
probably still 700 to 800k profit per 40
seeds done.
Um
and yeah, one more farm run under our
belt. Okay, so we bought all the
requirements to make air orbs. We got
1,000 empowered orbs, about 10 amulet of
glories, some anti-poisons, and 3,000
cosmic runes.
Uh I'm not sure if I'm going to take my
graceful set into the wilderness. I
probably should cuz I don't think you'd
lose it,
uh but I really, really don't want to
lose it.
Um we'll take a couple pieces at least.
We'll see what we need to bring cuz we
might not need it all actually. Okay, so
if you don't know, running air orbs is
pretty simple. I'm just in the Edgeville
dungeon. You're going to run like north
out past these chaos druids,
and then you're going to run past some
greater demons, and then there's a
little door that leads into the
wilderness.
So, technically, you could get killed by
somebody, but
there's just literally no point for
anyone to do it. They're not going to PK
anything of worth. They're just doing it
because they want to. I guess they're
black demons. Sorry. Um but yeah, up
this ladder, and then there is the orb.
This This just reminds me of the How was
that movie? 2001: A Space Odyssey with
the monkeys.
Yeah. Anyway, um yeah, so we're going to
make some air orbs, and we'll see how
much money we actually manage to make.
Okay, so we did the air orb charging for
1 hour, and we got 545 orbs.
Um on a side note, we did actually claim
all our money from the ranarrs, giving
us another 700k profit.
Um but in the 1 hour of doing it, we got
I think 35k XP for magic, which isn't
too bad, not nearly as quick as the
tele-alching.
Um but we are going to make some profit
as well.
And it's much more AFK-able.
Um so we are going to sell them for 1372
and it cost us 501 to buy the components
for.
Giving us about I think 800 and 871
in profit per orb and almost 500k per
hour in total. So pretty decent. Okay,
so we have actually a
task of rock slugs.
And I'm buying this brine saber because
it actually prevents you from having to
use the salt on the slugs, which is kind
of a fun little tip I figured out on the
wiki. Yeah, so you just wield the brine
saber and you automatically kill the
slugs. Bam. Yeah, that's way nicer.
I mean it does less damage than my
dragon scimitar, but it's it's worth it
in my eyes cuz I really dislike having
to focus so hard on using an item on a
creature when it's almost dead. It's
just a pain in the ass. Okay, there's
level 44 slayer. Um and we just have a
couple rock slugs left and then we get
to actually go for
the slayer master in Zanaris. Okay,
here's our first task from Chaeldar.
145 lesser demons. That's actually
pretty good experience per hour.
Definitely better than my more recent
tasks. And yeah, I think we're going to
cannon that for sure.
Okay, so we sold off all the air orbs.
Again, we got about 500k in profit from
that.
Um so not too bad and we bought another
40 ranarr seeds to go do another farm
run, uh which we're going to do right
now, but then after we'll kill those
lesser demons.
We also bought some more compost
potions.
We still have 300 in the bank from a
couple episodes ago, so we'll use all of
those eventually. I just don't feel like
doing it right now and the prices were a
bit lower than they I would have liked.
Uh so we just held off on doing that for
now, but we'll do that pretty soon.
Um but for now we're going to do some
slayer. Okay, so we're at lesser demons
and we're just trying to find a place I
can cannon them cuz it's a little
challenging. I don't know if there's
actually a safe spot I'm in the tar ly
dungeon.
Um but we'll see. It's pretty decent
experience per hour. I'm getting about
60k range experience as well as 20k
slayer experience.
Um which is
quite a bit better than what I've been
normally getting.
Um but we still have to find a safe
spot. Okay, so this is kind of working
as a safe spot.
Um it's a bit of a pain in the ass to do
cuz there isn't actually a safe spot.
This is just kind of clipping them onto
this rock here.
Um but not too bad and we're actually
about to hit a range level that will
give us 71 range. Um pretty exciting.
We're getting pretty high up there in
our range levels actually. Okay, that is
our 20th task completed in a row giving
us 50 slayer points. I didn't realize
we're on a 50th task or 20th task
already.
Um so those points will be a nice help.
I'm still kind of loosely saving up for
the slayer rings though.
And the slayer helmet I guess
eventually. Okay, now onto our second
task is going to be 135 cow fights. That
is a really good task as well. Easy to
cannon
and uh pretty good slayer and range
experience. Okay, so yeah, like I said,
really easy to do. We actually found an
open world right away.
Uh a task of 150 only takes like 20
minutes to complete. There's 46 slayer.
And we're getting up there. We're trying
to get 55 slayer like I said earlier.
Uh so hopefully we'll get that pretty
soon. Okay, we finished our task of cow
fights and we'll grab another task and
see if we want to do it.
Uh 150 pyre fiends.
Um I don't really want to do that right
now.
So I think that's what we're going to do
is we're going to end the episode
so I don't have to do it right now. So
hope you guys enjoyed. If you did, uh
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button. It'll be on screen for you
there.
And I will see you guys in the next
episode.